Ukraine's plight has prompted many
countries to offer help but when asked
what they need most Ukraine's leadership
have repeated a singular refrain as DW
reporter William gluecraft explains
Ukraine's foreign minister dimitro
culeba told NATO last week that all his
country was looking for is weapons lots
of them and more serious ones now so far
Western allies have delivered equipment
like anti-tank and anti-aircraft
missiles at least 17 000 such weapons
against tanks have come from NATO
members like the United States United
Kingdom and Germany they seem to have
proven highly effective against Russian
armor as have Turkish made drones armed
with air-to-surface missiles the tp-2
Drone has been a Workhorse for Ukrainian
forces the U.S may also deliver hundreds
of small fast drones called switchblades
that also go after armor now these sorts
of lighter weapons have beat back
Russian forces making them downsize
their War Ambitions and contain their
assault to Ukraine's East but to fully
defeat the Russian invasion Ukraine has
said it's been pounding allies for
heavier weapons such as tanks long range
artillery anti-ship missiles and
helicopters now some of these are on the
list of the 800 million dollars of new
military aid that U.S President Joe
Biden recently approved Western allies
are also trying to figure out if Eastern
European countries can send older
equipment that Ukrainian troops are
already familiar with which newer stock
could then replace the UK and the
European Union have been stepping up
efforts a total of 1.5 billion euros is
coming out of what the EU calls its
peace facility a budget for equipment
medical supplies and military aid
however it's Germany that's coming under
pressure to do more right now the
government is deadlocked over sending
heavy weapons for Ukraine foreign
minister Elena berbach and many others
have come out in favor but whether
Ukraine starts getting German tanks will
ultimately be a decision made by
Chancellor Olaf Schultz
well for more let's talk to Tim Ripley
he's a defense journalist and writer and
joins us from Lancaster in England hi
and welcome to DW now what weapons and
equipment would you say Ukraine needs
the most right now
well you've got to decide what the
Ukrainian War aims are are there war
aims to defend their cities and and uh
protect their their territory that they
hold now or is there a ambition to
actually launch an offensive and drive
the Russians back from all the territory
occupy from the donbass and retake
Crimea those are two different types of
objectives and they require two
different types of weapons at the moment
the Western allies NATO U.S UK have have
provided them the equipment to do the
first thing they have not offered up
heavy weapons tanks fighter planes
attack helicopters so the ukrainians
could take the offensive and drive an
attempt to drive the Russians from the
donbass and from Crimea that would be a
major escalation of the war
well Tim we have been hearing about the
the looming Russian assault in Ukraine's
east and south how do you see it panning
out
well this is a a an area where the
Russian advantages in tanks and
artillery will will give them a a an
edge over the ukrainians in a way that
they didn't when they were fighting
around Kiev in in the cities and in in
the in the towns this is open terrain it
was famously fought over by the the
German Army in World War II and the
Soviet Army Battle of cursed the biggest
tank battle of World War II was fought
in this area so it plays to the
Russell's strength they can maneuver
they can try and Surround what's left of
the Ukrainian Army and do what they've
done in marry a poll to other Ukrainian
uh units in that area and and and they
are trying to inflict a defeat on the
Ukrainian Army to force them to agree to
terms or allow the Russians to claim
victory and open the way for some sort
of negotiation face-saving negotiation
Tim you've just mentioned mariupole
there how important is the capture of
the city
well um I mean obviously it's a very
symbolic uh sign of a Ukrainian
resistance but from the Russian point of
view it it frees up tens of thousands of
troops to take part in offensive
offensives elsewhere in the country at
the moment you know the ukrainians and
the Russians have been fighting Street
to Street in in mariopol taking up
several thousand troops on either side
and that is a you know hindering the
ability of the Russians to attack
elsewhere it's almost like the uh you
can compare it to the Battle of
Stalingrad in World War II where the the
German forces were fought to the last in
stangrad to give the the German forces
elsewhere in Russia a chance to regroup
and that's what ukrainians I'm doing in
mariopol that every time every day
they've held out in mariopol has given
their defenses elsewhere in the country
a chance to build up
and briefly if you could now Russia's uh
Black Sea Flagship is now underwater the
mosque about what effect if any could
its last have on the conflict
it's again it's a more symbolic
um uh episode I mean the Russians have
you know
20 or 30 warships in the Black Sea Fleet
they completely outnumber the ukrainians
uh and they're not going to be
challenged in the Black Sea even with
the loss of the Moscow but it's a morale
booster for the ukrainians rather than a
military sort of impact on the Russian
Fleet
Tim Ripley thanks for sharing your
expertise on DW welcome
you're welcome